the biden administration's attempts to
hide this crisis instead of actually
fixing it is so bad
that even texas state officials state
officials their state
are apparently being blocked from
entering this emergency facility
for unaccompanied minors inside the
convention center in dallas texas take a
look at this
today i am directly asking the biden
administration
to allow the texas department of public
safety to
access this facility across the street
at the k bailey hutchison center
as well as the other federally run
facilities in texas
to be able to talk to these
unaccompanied minors
we must get to the bottom of the human
trafficking
and put an end to it joining us now with
much more the texas governor himself
governor greg abbott governor i i heard
the passion in your voice tell us
exactly what you're dealing with down
there
because number one they won't even allow
you as governor of your state
to even enforce what is the legal law of
the land correct
that's correct sean listen this has
turned into a total catastrophe
and it's getting worse by the day you
heard griff talking about the increased
numbers
americans need to know this this is just
the very beginning
of what's going to be a massive
expansion
of the number of people coming across
the border it will grow
tenfold in a hundred fold especially
because of the way
the bite administration has handled this
remember during the presidential
campaign when all of the candidates said
we want open borders well guess what
biden
has provided those open borders he's
inviting
everybody in and the floodgates are now
open
and texas is at the forefront of it
we're having to deal with these
massive numbers of migrants
whether it be 3000 in dallas or however
many they're sitting in midland or
however many they have a carissa springs
and the reason why i say however many
is because we can't get the data you had
jin saki talking about
wanting to be transparent the body
administration is not being transparent
with either the governor of texas or the
texas
department of state health services we
need to know what the health situation
of these kids are we need to know
if they've been exposed to variants of
covid and if so
is it the brazilian variant or whatever
type of variance
our law enforcement the texas department
of public safety they need to do their
job
part of their job is making sure they
track down and prosecute
anybody involved in smuggling once the
kids get over
to the state of texas they are still
involved with coyotes and smugglers and
people like that that
we do have the ability to rest and put
behind bars the binding administration
is not letting us gain access to that
information
so that we can arrest and prosecute
those who are assisting
this immigration process so so governor
let me make sure that we're clear here
people that didn't respect our laws our
sovereignty and our borders that are in
your state
illegally you are now being prevented
from enforcing the law
and you are even being prevented from
checking
on children these undocumented
immigrant children to number one check
their safety to check their health to
do your job and due diligence that you
would normally do correct
absolutely correct we have sought access
to these shelters and we've been denied
access
to those shelters whether it be
involving health care purposes
or talking to these children
about human trafficking you've got some
young children
who've been trafficked across mexico and
maybe some other countries and
who knows what horrific things may have
happened to them what i can tell you is
texas has
a top-notch human trafficking
prosecution unit
and we want to be involved and learn the
information so that we can crack
down on this human trafficking mission
sean we need to we need to expose this
for what it is
because president biden continues to
invite in
young children with the promise of them
being able to stay here
these children make a very dangerous
trek where they have to encounter
cartels uh drug dealers
gang members ms-13 gang members and
there could be horrific things happening
to them we know the legacy
of the human trafficking that happens to
these children
it must be stopped let me let me ask you
uh and even my orcas the department of
homeland security secretary
first that denied it's a crisis even he
now is acknowledging it's a crisis
we now we see a prediction it's going to
be a 20-year high here
now you're the governor of your state
you have an obligation a sworn oath and
a duty
to uphold the law my question to you is
in light of what's happening
in dallas and light of what's happening
at the border
what it what are the remedies and
options you have available
to you we are we're assessing all tools
i will offer this up
and i'll tell you what my expectation is
because last week i was on the border
and i talked to border patrol officers
and they told me at the time that the
administration had not provided border
patrol officers
with coveted vaccines and i called up
the blind administration and said they
needed to correct it
and they did my hope is that the same
thing will happen this time and that is
i've called out the blind administration
for not allowing us into
these facilities for not cracking down
on human trafficking
for not addressing the kova situation of
these children as well as the welfare of
the children as well as not even having
facilities capable of taking care of
these children
the body administration is not prepared
for the massive
inflow of humanity that's coming to the
lone star state
and so i hope that they will respond to
this plea
as quickly as they respond to the one i
issued last week if there's any of these
cargo shipping containers
um could you please have some of your
guys take pictures and give them to us
because america has a right to know
what's inside those cargo shipping
containers because i think we both know
that if donald trump ever put children
in them um i think there would be quite
a bit of an outcry governor
just guessing though all right we wish
you the best governor abbott
tough situation down there